التوتر الامريكي الصيني المتزايد يدفعنا
الى التساؤل حول امكانيه بكين العسكريه
البحريه منها خاصه في حال اندلاع حرب مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اصول السفن
الحربيه الصينيه يتطور بشكل متسارع ما
يشكل ازمه متناميه للولايات المتحده التي
تبحث كافه الطرق بمواكبه ذلك فالبحريه
الصينيه هي الاكبر في العالم وتفوقها
وتفوقها العدد على الولايات المتحده يتسع
حتى ان قائد البحريه الامريكيه حذر مؤخرا
من انهم لا يستطيعون مواكبه التسارع
الصيني التقديرات العسكريه تقول ان الصين
قادره على بناء ثلاث سفن حربيه في الوقت
الذي تستغرقه الولايات المتحده لبناء
واحده عدديا وبحسب تقديرات بانتاجون تمتلك
البحريه الصينيه حوالي
340 سفينه حربيه بينما تمتلك الولايات
المتحده اقل من 300 سفينه الدفاع
الامريكيه تعتقد ان الاسطول الصيني سينمو
الى 400 في المقبلين بينما سيستغرق الاصول
الامريكي حتى عام 2045 ليصل الى 350 سفينه
حربيه المخاوف الامريكيه لا تقتصر على
التفوق العدد المتزايد للبحريه الصينيه بل
على حقيقه مفادها ان بعض السفن التي
تنتجها الصين لديها قوه نيران اكبر من بعض
نظراتها الامريكيه فالمدمره
55 هنا نتحدث عن مدمره 55 صينيه والتي
يصنفها البعض كواحده من اقوى المدمرات في
العالم
055 بابين اثني عشر الفا الى 13 الف طن
وهي اكبر من المدمرات النموذجيه واقرب في
الحجم الى فئه الطرادات تايكون ديروغا
تابعه للبحريه الامريكيه تمتلك 122 خليه
لنظام الاطلاق العمودي فباستطاعه اطلاق
صواريخ ارض جو وصواريخ مضاده للسفن بينما
احدث مدمر البحريه الامريكيه من فئه علب
الركوه هي تمتلك 96 خليه لنظام الاطلاق
العمودي تعمل الصين على تضخيم اصولها من
هذه المدمرات حيث بدات في بناء هذا الطراز
عام 2014 واطلقت مؤخرا نسختها الثامنه
شيان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات